what's going on everybody and welcome to
another Raspberry Pi tutorial in this
tutorial what we're gonna be talking
about is accessing your Raspberry Pi
remotely from your local network you can
access your Raspberry Pi from anywhere
in the world you can set that up but
that has a lot less to do with the
Raspberry Pi itself and more to do with
your actual network and that's a much
more advanced tutorial we're not gonna
be getting into that so there's two
major ways to connect to your Raspberry
Pi one is via some sort of remote
desktop and the other is via just SSH
which is secure shell both have their
own good benefits to them so you would
do like a remote desktop if you have any
sort of UI or if you've got video that
you want to show or you just don't you
you want to actually just share the the
keyboard and mouse on some computer
between the Raspberry Pi and all that
you don't have to hook it up every time
so the first thing that we need to do to
remotely access the PI is make sure we
were connected in some way to the local
network you come up here to your Wi-Fi
click on that you can't see it actually
because my face is in the way there you
can choose your Wi-Fi make sure you're
connected or you can connect you know
physically with an Ethernet cable or
whatever now once you've got that go
ahead and do your ctrl alt and T and
that should open up a your terminal now
I want to make it a little larger so
everybody can see and hopefully that's
not too large let's see what we get yeah
love it so so now we're going to go
ahead and do is you could do if' config
and that will give you a bunch of
information if you are connected
physically it would probably your
internet IP address would be up here but
I'm not connected physically I'm
actually connected via a wireless LAN so
that's down here and what you're looking
for is your eye net address my address
is 192 168 1 92 168 0 103 ok so we have
that information now what we want to do
is see if I could get
to the bottom of this I've clearly made
this too big let's go down a little bit
um once we've done that once we have
that we could in theory connect to the
Raspberry Pi but it's not going to let
us because the SSH server is disabled by
default now on the raspberry PI's if you
have an older Raspberry Pi actually I
suppose it would come with the
installation so are they like your
actual operating system so it used to be
the case that SSH was always just
enabled by default but as more and more
people are using raspberry PI's they're
using them in their businesses and all
that it has become a better idea to not
do that because if people got open Wi-Fi
they just need to find the raspberry
PI's IP address they know the default
login and password so that can be
problematic
so generally if you do have the ssh
server enabled and you using the default
username and password it's gonna keep
warning you by the way you're doing this
and stupid anyway
we're gonna open up the r a spy config
so do sudo maybe and I'm still not
on-screen I don't think let's see if I
can do this I think we're just typing
off-screen yeah so what you want to do
is sudo rasp I - config hit enter and
this is the configuration for your
Raspberry Pi you know a whole bunch of
stuff you can change the password you
can change your host name you can do
Boot Options or interested in
interfacing options let's go ahead and
enter there and we want to enable SSH so
go ahead and enter here and would you
like the ssh server to be enabled yes
boom done okay so now ssh is enabled and
we can connect so at this point we
actually can connect via ssh now if you
aren't familiar with ssh I will hit
finish
basically on Windows you're going to
need something like putty so PU TTY you
can go to putty org download that and
you can connect that way or if you're on
Macintosh or Linux it's as simple as
opening up your terminal and doing SSH
username which would be PI at whatever
your IP address is in my case it was 192
168 0 103 so you could do that and
connect
now if you're on Windows it's a little
more challenging
oops I've already got this one's already
up but basically let's do new session
you'd come over here and you type in the
IP address so 192 168 0 103 hit enter
this will pop up asks you to login I'll
log in is PI password is raspberry by
default connected and boom and as you
can see ssh is enabled and the default
password for pi has not been changeable
wha and the next time we log in to the
actual GUI desktop we'll also have
another warning there telling us that
we're probably making a big mistake
so okay so that's how you can SSH into
the Raspberry Pi once you do that it's
basically the command line and as you
can see and so now we can do all kinds
of stuff here once you've done that like
I was saying before if there are any
times where you want a GUI desktop for
whatever reason so you can also do a
remote desktop now for this on Windows
and Mac you probably the easiest is just
to download remote desktop by Microsoft
I think Mac also has a remote desktop
software I'm not sure
and then on Linux its gr desktop so GUI
remote desktop gr desktop so that would
be gr desktop like so otherwise if
you're on Mac or Windows its virtual or
M sorry its remote desktop by Microsoft
Microsoft ok if you're on Windows you
should already have it now in order to
get there what we need to do is install
some sort of remote desktop client on
the Raspberry Pi
I choose X RDP if you have already tried
to sell xrdp and it failed for whatever
reason in the past it was easier now
it's harder for some reason because you
already have a VNC server you might need
to run sudo apt-get remove xrdp
VNC for server and tight VNC server if
you've already tried to install you
might need to run that command just to
remove everything and start clean
otherwise if you are clean you should be
able to just do sudo apt-get
install tight VNC server server now I
already have it so this should be done
and then you can do sudo apt-get install
xrdp if for whatever reason something
gets when we when you go to connect and
it doesn't work for whatever reason it
hangs or whatever go ahead and run that
thing to just clear everything and try
again
so once you've got xrdp installed you're
good to go
you you could restart the service xrdp
but it should be enabled by default once
you install now on Windows what you can
do is open remote desktop and in here
you can type the IP address I'm actually
one of three it connects yes and then
here's your like your login screen now
you can type PI raspberry hit enter and
if you hang here that's probably when
you'll want to do your you know remove
everything and try again otherwise here
we are in the remote desktop now because
I already have a remote desktop it's
just showing me like a copy of this
other one because this is also a remote
desktop connection but normally you
won't share it like so this is not on
the screen on the actual Raspberry Pi
and I can even turn it on and show you
that that is not showing you know this
stuff here and if you are on a remote
desktop and you're trying to show
something from the res by camera by
default it's actually going to show on
that screen I'm not positive if you
unplug the HDMI if it would work but
anyway no big deal but just know
sometimes it can be kind of screwy
anyway that's it for the remote desktop
and remote connection SSH all that fun
stuff if you're having a problem you got
questions whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I'll see you in the
next tutorial where we're going to be
talking about actual terminal navigation
and commands and all that kind of stuff
so I will see you in the next tutorial